[Music]
so you know stuff about india i guess
i guess i probably know more stuff about
america is all right we're all man
whoever is born
what happened on june 20th
in india depends on what year duh
capital riots you got it dude you got it
are we talking about 1000 bc or are we
talking about 500. straight up and
insulted me you like
that as in like today what's today's
date what's to the real what's your 23rd
today's june 23rd
i shouldn't say that because this video
is gonna be yeah three years all right
so uh time capsule this video is a time
capsule yeah there's uh there's an
elephant indeed you know there's
elephants uh oh yeah okay cool we're on
same page yeah this elephant in india
that
comes into town and kills this old woman
tramples her i heard about this
oh this was the revenge killing of the
elephant and then returns to trample her
corpse again at her funeral why that's
crazy memory baby how could you not
[ __ ] believe in spiritual what did
she do to that guy she [ __ ] that
animal up bro what did she do okay i
think the professional answer that the
media is giving at the end of the day is
talking about how like you know there's
too much uh what you know what's the
[ __ ] term when uh um overpopulation
kind of like that or identifying like
the [ __ ] areas so they actually the
small the area that is wild or the
environment that's wild for for these
animals to be in it starts to get
smaller and then so they start you know
coming into like [ __ ] move to vegas
and utah there's plenty of land so
they're [ __ ] with their habitat
basically [ __ ] up their habitat why
they go to vegas in utah can elephants
exist in the you know buffalo
plains well i mean the alpha can sustain
what do elephants eat fruits
vegetables they'll survive in the grand
canyon i think they'll get poached
put them all in the grand canyon you
think americans would start shooting
[ __ ] yeah yeah of course they shoot
everything immediately once they find
out how much they could get their toys
have you seen the uh monkey people wars
the monkeys no monkey dog wars so that
whole that whole theme where you're
moving into the habitat you're on the
planet of the apes no they have so like
their their uh their dogs their dogs
yeah the monkeys will take their dogs
and bring them up to like the top of a
tree and start dropping them yeah i
thought that's because the stray dogs
and monkeys were warring because the
stray dogs were fighting over the food
with the monkeys and then they would
bite the monkeys and kill them so then
the monkeys started getting the puppies
and throwing them over the
the houses and [ __ ] yeah
make sense monkey dogs dude survival of
the fittest i mean we're just
cutting trees down i don't know but they
die anyways yeah that's true we're all
pieces of [ __ ] so what's up with
security why can't they keep the same
elephant out uh yeah what's up security
so on june 10th 2022
uh the woman named maya murmu who hailed
from rye paul village
uh ring a bell
in the district of
meyer
dude
i don't know what you're reading dude
i'm just speaking indian this is you're
good this is good i'm gonna i want i
want you to read it as is so the comment
section below dude you know you know
maya murmur exactly the right paul
villarreal i probably have it in the
district odisha meyer bonjour definitely
have a cousin there she was brutally
attacked by an elephant in a nearby
force of cousin vegeta in a nearby
forest while collecting water according
to news reports she was rushed to the
hospital where she was pronounced dead
very quickly after
and after bringing her body home her
family proceeded to make the necessary
arrangements for her funeral but it was
all for notch as on the day of her
funeral the very same elephant returned
to the village in an extremely foul mood
did it trample everybody during the not
everybody else but it was really just
her and like the rest of you came right
back to her no none of this is really
making any sense it sounds personal she
went in get water who collected her body
she was there by herself i'm i'm on the
elephant side
so was she cremated
no no it's her corpse it said the
elephant then proceeded to attack their
funeral and targeted maya's corpse she
was trampling it furiously before
letting out a roar that signaled other
elephants from his herd to wreck the
rest of the thing ah he brought back
looks like a turf war this sounds like a
straight up yeah you need an elephant
expert the same elephant somehow managed
to identify maya's home and went on uh
to smash it killing the goats living
there as well whoa goats too i didn't
know elephants [ __ ] up goats like that
by the end nearly the entire village had
been wrecked and many of the inhabitants
had lost their homes [ __ ] this is
elephant in ms-13 or some [ __ ]
some cartel style [ __ ] i know i'm not
gonna lie though the village must have
been pretty small it must be like a real
village or the elephant's huge i mean
it's a normal elephant elephants are
elvis known to attack unprovoked that's
the thing tony i want to see them [ __ ]
up a go like if you're tony jaw and
you're doing muay thai strikes from the
top of their trunks
strikes from the top of their trunks
dumbo drop they weren't very those
elephants weren't very you know they
were very friendly but it's almost like
getting into a fight with a bulldozer
who remembers that these guys don't
remember elephants
dude
crickets from everybody else though are
they also small enough to be carried by
cranes
storks they fit in crates oh yeah they
do in the movie right in the movie they
like fall on the crates they're like
this is why they like come out right
like
see no crickets here buddy
is this a cartoon or is this like a hot
shots type of blade
shots
it's actually the bonus episode of
planet earth they show all the alcohol
in there narrated by david attenborough
so it happens at the end of soaring over
california
if you're gonna if you get a group of
just asians they show just the asian
portion of the planet i'm sorry
california yeah yeah but it's a really
exclusive group it's like it's like it's
like
unlocked you've unlocked it like you
know it's just them going over the great
wall of china like five times that guy
who's like welcome welcome
mr incredible he's right yeah welcome to
soaring california
i see we have a full group of asians
today we'll just go over
asia
no california california
today we're just going through the san
gabriel valley
[Laughter]
soaring over 66.
as you can see here is artesia
where all the indians in la are
is that really where all the indians
were it's like the eight that's like the
little india
own artesia artesia yeah
what does sona chandi mean i said a name
so this is part of the sound right now
it's part of the show i'm the only guy
to
okay it's on artesia and
[ __ ] i don't know i don't speak hindi
so i know the family that owns that you
do the uh son is a b-boy
wait an indian sean sean milani yeah
yeah
so sean is friends with uh me and joe's
friend alec
shawn that's crazy with a small world do
you remember going to uh
so it's like it's an entire
indian
uh shop with like like saris and stuff
yeah and then in that whole complex
there's a streetwear store in the middle
of it
it's gone now but he tried america's
streetwear indian streetwear like
hypebeast
like graffiti graffiti that must be for
all the kids of all the shop owners
they're like [ __ ] it was called the
deuce
was it like hypebeast stuff yeah yeah it
was like all like limited streetwear
stuff back back in the day like
karmaloop era but this dude
he was like one of the only like indian
b-boys and his his b-boy name was habib
boy
that's sick
is it habib middle eastern i guess yeah
it's more arabic
so why would he's taking advantage of
the stereotypes i know right he's just
rolling with because punjabi was taken
he's a he's a welder now he's a welder
or like like a straight like a real
welder like god is he got his like his
license and he's on he's part of the
union now you need a welding license for
welding i just remember seeing
vietnamese people
i'm there with a lighter i'm like this
isn't hot enough this isn't melting
anything where they scooch the ladder
over with their legs yes
and then they got a cigarette in their
mouth the whole time they're doing it
and they don't take breaks they just
sleep on a cardboard box on the floor
the way they cover their face you don't
talk about right they don't [ __ ] have
now they don't even see what they're
doing oh my god yeah it looks well dude
style baby talk about dangerous jobs fun
fact
deep sea welding is top three most
dangerous jobs
yeah you'll die you gotta be under water
too right you'll die you'll [ __ ] die
i thought you were in the deep sea but
above the water
oh you were just like far out in there
yeah yeah yeah yeah
like crabby like just like an oil rig
you gotta love something but you gotta
take it on your boat all the way to the
side
no you're not like you're fixing a boat
like you're fixing one of those
boats ocean or whatever open ocean yeah
crap out of crabbing
i actually don't know if it's called
welder
but i know it has to do with underwater
[ __ ] welding in a scuba gear but it's
one of the most dangerous [ __ ] jobs
because i thought the torch is just hot
enough like how does that work i don't
know like it has a lot of like uh what
do you call it like a lot of uh just
holding two axle shrimps people get hurt
how do they start a fire underwater no
the torch the torch is small
you're just holding the pistol strips
get it hyperbaric welding yeah i'm
looking i'm looking at photos of this
[ __ ] right because i thought being a cop
was the most dangerous job right
[Laughter]
being a deep seat
come on guys
that's the day just
deep sea cop right there dude deep sea
cops shooting something that's a tight
ass show that's that's crazy did you
just think about all the things that you
could learn in this world and it's like
don't mean [ __ ] you could be you could
be a deep sea welder or
you could start your own hentai
corporation
so many jobs
corporations it's a corporate if you're
starting it's a corporation
yeah
they could be the same uh
he's going company under the same name
he's actually welding going to go to the
deep sea to come out with his ideas oh
see welder comes up for air
he'll go back and be like okay
i've got my idea he's perfect dude needs
to unload from a stressful day and
that's where i come in
that's when we didn't find the venn
diagram of deep sea welders in hentai
porn
what's in the middle i like the story i
like the story because he's tired right
so he's like he's probably away from his
his home so he's on the on the pier and
there's a hotel there and he meets the
lovely receptionist and that's when the
game starts no dude he doesn't he just
plays on his phone he just comes up on
the boat yeah and he gets to fantasize
about all the things i was talking about
he's a character in the hentai game oh
that's even better
that's specificity this is where
i am the owner of the company and you're
not because while he's welding
he's getting sucked off by a [ __ ]
mermaid that's what i'm talking about
like a tentacle monster right so it's
kind of sci-fi too but he's still neat
you need to like have him spit game at
the mermaid yeah and figure out how to
get some sirens so you can throw some
sirens in there whole like poseidon
themed oh yeah
he's like don't [ __ ] my wife
it's like yeah this driver just tried to
decide
oh [ __ ] my [ __ ]
wall that's the boss that's the thing
and then it cuts it's like
you could [ __ ] torch his ass though i
know i'm not scared of him no more
that's a good battle the underwater you
know this already sounds way better than
the [ __ ] aquaman movie it is i was
like that aquaman but because you said
that i'm gonna cut them out this is the
writer's room for aquaman right now you
know that that movie you pitched to me a
long time ago about the the dildo battle
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i think if you
guys made that into a video game it
actually would be successful dildo wars
well whatever like if it was an rpg you
played as the mom the number one
prostitute and you just did the wars and
you play as the mom or whoever the main
character was yeah there was like that
gang van going on the sun the sun
and then he's just like losing his [ __ ]
well he hears it right yeah i don't know
he might be onto something just think
about it workshop we need investors so
he can make these games come to life
[Music]
you